- What's up Believe Nation it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in you
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey
today I'm going to talk about
seven ways to be more disciplined.
(hip hop music)
So staying disciplined, staying focused,
staying on task is one of the
hardest things for especially
creative entrepreneurs
to do because we have all
these things that we want
to do when we're in our head
and dreaming and envisioning.
But then we actually have to do the work
and be disciplined about it.
So I thought I'd share
with you my seven tips
on how to be successful doing it.
Tip number one is create
a morning routine.
You have to start off right.
So many times it happens
with entrepreneurs
and it happened to me
so many multiple times,
you get inspired randomly.
I would get inspired randomly.
I would meet somebody at
for coffee and we'd be
bubbling ideas and I get so inspired
and go home and work.
Or listen to a YouTube video
or read a book or something
that would just fire me up.
And I'd be working like
crazy and then the next day
we'll wake up and like
poof, it's like it's gone.
I'm starting over from scratch.
I felt like I start over from scratch
and I still do, I feel
like I start from scratch
every single day.
The baseline becomes
maybe a little bit higher
over time, but I'm still
starting off from scratch.
I don't wake up energized, passionate,
ready to go attack the day.
You know ,that's not me
at least maybe that's you,
maybe that's some people if
that's you you're probably
watching this video.
But I think most people wake
up starting from scratch.
I think we put on this
entrepreneur mask of like yeah
I'm hosting hard I'm
grinding but we wake up
and we're not we're not grinding,
we're not we're not super motivated.
It doesn't mean we hate
our life but we know
we could be working harder.
I think you need a daily reset
and it's figuring out what is
the one thing that gets you
inspired, that gets you passionate,
that gets you motivated.
To get you, it's like I want
to go do something today.
You've all felt that feeling before.
I know the way it is for
me, a lot of times it's it's
the videos it's watching
successful people having success.
But that's what I want to do
and seeing it on a regular
basis makes me want to do it.
So I made the channel
selfishly for myself too,
like the top ten, they're meant
for me, all those is for me.
I want to see, it I want
to get motivated, I want
to be inspired, I want
to learn knowledge yes.
But just seeing people doing great things
makes me want to do great things.
so that's what helps me,
so start your day with it.
It's why I did the Enspresso
Series, like start your day
with a shot of an
enspresso to get you going.
But if that's not your thing, it's cool.
You don't have to watch
my channel, I get it.
Read a book, meet with a friend,
listen to a podcast.
Whatever the thing is
there's no judgment you know
like playing with your
ring gets you excited
or waxing your eyebrows
or whatever it is like
it doesn't matter.
Whatever the thing is
that gets you like rah,
this day is going to be
great, do that every day.
Start your day with it because
if you start your day off
on the wrong foot or
you start your day off
just falling into your schedule
you may not be inspired
the whole day.
Or you may randomly come across something
at four o'clock that day
and then that's what
gets you all motivated
but you've lost from when
you wake up tp four o'clock.
Right, there's a lot of time
in there that could have
been way more productive
focusing on important things.
And so find the thing
that gets you motivated,
that gets you energized
and start your day with it
every single day.
Tip number two is create
a regular schedule.
I think it's way easier
to be disciplined when you
have a schedule that you are following.
One of the hardest things
I think for entrepreneurs
is we have to balance this thing
if we want creative freedom,
we want creative expression,
we want to be able
to do what we want to do.
But also we need to have
some kind of routine,
some kind of discipline
because left to our own means
we may not wake up and
do anything on that day
or at least anything
of substance or values.
It's easy to get
distracted by other things
and it's not furthering our goals.
And so what I find really helps for me is
I create a regular schedule
and every day I kind
of know what I'm doing.
And I chunk my time some
Mondays are one thing
and Tuesday's another thing
and Wedenesday's another thing and so on
for the rest of the week.
And when I wake up on a
Monday morning I don't have to
think about what I'm doing today .
It's already there, it's on my list.
I have my tasks I know
what I'm doing Monday.
I start with a great morning ritual
and then I'm into my day.
Right.
And I think that helps most of the time.
I think on the rare occasion
that you feel inspired by
something else like I wake
up and I want to really
want to go off and do that
I'll often go out and do that
and cancel everything else
that I was working on for that day.
Because chances are what
I create in that moment
is going to be gold.
Like when you're in the flow
and you're really feeling
some thing what's going
to come out of that
is going to be golden.
The challenge is you're
not in the flow every day,
at least me I'm not in flow every day.
I don't wake up and flow I'm
just like a whole day of flow
and I'm ready to go.
That's not me, if that's you,
great, ignore this point.
But most people don't
wake up and just flow
the whole day.
And so I had the routine for
when videos most of my days
and then when I'm in flow I
go and follow that passion.
At the same time when I feel like my
something's missing or
feel like I want to add
something else to my schedule I mean
something else has to be pulled out.
And so whenever I feel like
the work that I'm doing
in my calendar is not matching
up to what I want to do
I have a vision, I have
dreams, I have other interests
I want to pursue.
Then I start to change my schedule.
So the schedule is what
I live by, it's what I
wake up and do on most days.
And if I know it's in my
schedule it's going to get done.
Super important because
left to my own devices
I would still be productive
but nowhere near as
productive, nowehere near as disciplined.
And so knowing what
you're going to do when
you wake up but not having
to make choices on the side
every single time makes life a lot easier.
Tip number three is track your progress.
There's a famous expression
that what gets measured
gets done or gets accomplished.
When you are tracking what
you're doing you're more
likely to pay attention
to it and want to fix it.
And so you know if your
goal is to lose weight
if you're tracking your weight every day
and you're tracking
your calories every day
you're much more likely to lose weight.
You know if your goal is
to call 10 customers a day
or reach out to ten people a day.
Or you know make a
YouTube video every week
if you are tracking it
then you're more likely
to follow through on it.
Just like when you're making
goals, the more specific
you are the more likely
you're going to hit it.
If your goal is to just lose weight
then you're unlikely to do it.
But if your goal is to lose 10 pounds
or 20 pounds, or your
goal is to hit you know
$50,000 and more revenue
or whatever your goal is
you're more likely to hit it
because you're being specific.
And so if you're tracking
it on a daily basis
or a weekly basis, then you
want to hit those numbers.
You know when I'm working
out with my personal trainer
you know he gives me goals I need to hit.
Yeah I need to hit 900
calories a week in cardio
as an example right now.
So I have to do 45 minutes in two chunks
45 minutes in 45 minutes
on the on the machine.
And I'm on social media is you
guys can check me out there
when I'm answering your questions.
Would I do 45 minutes without him?
Maybe, maybe I'd do 15 minutes.
Say, yeah okay, I'll do some cardio.
Right but if you're
tracking it and you know
it's happening and you make a
spreadsheet or use a checklist
or whatever it is how you want to track
don't get caught up in the
tools the tools don't matter.
It could be a piece of paper
and a pen when you're checking
something off and you
know you've got it done
you're much more likely to follow through.
What gets tracked gets done.
So anything you want
to stay disciplined on
have some kind of
tracking system in place.
Email or Evernote or a CRM or
a calendar, anything.
Something just so that you're
tracking it consistently.
Tip number four is
commit to somebody else.
When you commit to somebody
else you're much more likely
to follow through.
The reason is we will
let other people down
less than we'll let ourselves down.
It's easy to let ourselves down.
How many times do we say
I'm going to do something
but then you don't do it.
You're letting yourself down right.
Constantly.
Even for you guys who snooze
I'm going to talk about that yet
it's not on my list but let's go here now,
don't snooze, stop
hitting the snooze button.
The thing that happens when
you hit the snooze button is
I'm going to wake up at 8:00 AM.
Or I'm going to wake up at 7:00 AM
and the first thing
you do is say that goal
is not important to me.
That's not going to happen.
The first thing you do
every morning if you hit
the snooze button is let yourself down.
That's how you start your day.
And if you hit the
snooze button five times
you start your day every
day by letting yourself down
five times.
How well do you think that goes
for you to have a great day?
Stop hitting the snooze button
You're snoozing, you're
snoozing on everything,
you're snoozing on your dreams,
you're snoozing on your life.
Stop it, get up.
Back to the story.
So when you commit to
somebody else you more
likely to follow through.
I do this in my work out
as an example you know
I commit to my wife Nina and
Shawn our personal trainer
that on Mondays and Wednesdays
we're going to work out.
I'm there at five o'clock and we work out.
If I'm feeling tired if I'm
feeling you know stressed out
lots of work it's easy
to say you know what,
I'm not going to do that,
that's not important.
But because they're going to be there
I'm going to be there.
When I come in on Mondays
to work at Toronto here
I work with Alex and I work with Lily
and they're going to be
here and they're expecting
me to be here we have a meeting set
and I have to go over stuff with them .
I have to show up I'm not
going to let them down.
So whatever goal you have,
whatever you want to stay more
disciplined with, try to
line up somebody to be with,
try to line up a meeting
try, to line up a schedule.
Try to line up something with
somebody else because if you
commit to them you're more
likely to follow through.
Tip number five is have
big whys and little whys.
It's really important to
have a big why to feel like
what you're doing is
inspiring, is motivating.
There's a reason for you
to get up and do work.
If you feel like the work
you're doing is not important
you're not going to
stay disciplined on it.
If you feel like the work you're
doing is just pushing paper
and just filling out forms and grunt work
and administrative work, it's
something you don't care about
you're not going to work hard.
If you feel your work is
meaningless you don't want to
work hard on that.
It's really hard to say disciplined on it.
And so having a big why and know that
the work that you're doing
matters, it means something
to people, you're working toward building
a better life for yourself.
Whether you're thinking
about yourself and that
ideal life you're trying to build
whether you think about
your family, your community
or the customers you're serving
having a big why helps you stay motivated.
So for me I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs
that's a big scary ambitious goal, right.
Can I can I do it, is it possible?
The work I do has meaning.
I'm making these videos
trying to extend that goal.
It's not just oh I've
got to fill more videos
as soon as I get to that
point I'm done on YouTube.
If I dread the thought of
coming in and making videos
or if it's just okay like yeah whatever
got to go make some videos
I'm done, I have to move
on to something else.
You have to do meaningful work.
And so thinking about
what your big goal is,
what your big vision is,
the change you want to make
and looking at that on a regular
basis, keeping that in mind
and seeing how your work ties into you
accomplishing that big
goal is really important.
That's your big why.
At the same time you have your little whys
because the big why takes a long time.
The big why is a lifetime goal right
or a year goal or five year
like it it's out there,
it's not going to happen today,
it's not going to happen tomorrow.
And so thinking long-term sometimes can
be very motivating but
sometimes it can also
bring you down sometimes it can also
make you feel depressed like
I'm never going to hit that.
Or, who am I to hit that big goal?
I can't go out and do these big things.
And so it doesn't always serve
you to the best that it can.
And so that's why the little
whys are really important
and the little whys are the
day-to-day little meanings
that you have in your business.
So for me is an example the big whys
is helping a billion entrepreneurs.
The little why are the
comments that you guys leave
the little why is logging
everyday and seeing that
you know Johnny really loved my video
and it made a big impact.
Like your comments mean a lot to me.
I look at them every day it inspires me
and it inspires my team.
And we know that yes we're
helping millions of people right
we have millions of views
every month happening
on the channel, we've had
over 100 million views
on the channel.
It's numbers it's hard to even
imagine 100 million people
watching these videos.
But then to know that this
one person liked it and
appreciated it and talked
about the impact that it had.
Those day to day interactions
are really important.
When I was first getting
started up in this business
of helping entrepreneurs I would find
this huge spike of enjoyment
when I did I did speaking engagements.
And I would speak and just feel so great.
But it may be two weeks
until my next speaking gig
and then in between I felt down like
I didn't have anything like what,
I'm not getting any feedback,
I don't know that my work is
meaningful or contributing.
And so I would make a PowerPoint file
that I would watch every morning
and in it I would include
some of the feedback
from the people who are in my sessions,
some of the complimentary
things that people
had to say for me to feel like yeah,
the work I do is meaningful, it matters.
And it's a little why it's
not solving a big problem,
it's helping one person with one thing
they had in their business.
So I think that combination feeling like
you're doing something
important on a big scale
and also knowing that
the work you do today
is touching one person's
life and have an impact
it's easier much easier to
stay disciplined and on track.
Tip number six is have
a designated workplace.
This is really important
for entrepreneurs who
are working from home.
It can be hard when you have
all the comforts of your
home to float in between and try to work
in the kitchen and work on the couch
and work from your bedroom or
wherever it is that you work.
It can be hard to stay on task.
It's easy to get distracted
by oh what's in the fridge.
Oh what's on TV.
Oh who's that calling.
Oh the dog needs to be walked.
They're all of the little
tasks that kind of come up
and get you distracted.
If you have an easy time seeing focus then
it doesn't matter right
it doesn't matter at all, you're fine.
But you're not watching this video because
you have a hard time staying disciplined
and you want some tips.
And so I would suggest having
designated place to work
and also a designated time
so that you know from nine AM to one PM
you're going to work at this place.
And maybe that's outside the home,
it could be leaving, it could
be going to a coffee shop
or going to a library or going to a place
of business somewhere that
you're going to go out there
and work.
Or it could be designated
spot and you know
you have a home office in the
garage that you're setting up
and when you're there you work.
And when you're not there
then you don't work.
And I think that makes
it easier for people
who have a hard time staying disciplined.
You create a routine that
allows you to stay disciplined.
So an example when Alex
and Lily both started
working for me and where I'm
helping mentor and coach them
to become entrepreneurs
I give them options like you
can either work from home,
you can either work with
me, you can work from TDS,
you can work from my place,
you can follow me around,
you can whatever you want
to do whatever works best
for your schedule, whatever works best
for your personality style.
And if they want to be
around me all the time
and that helps going to keep consistency
and like show up here
at nine o'clock great.
If they want to work
from home or work from
a coffee shop great.
But creating a schedule
helps especially if
you're not the discipline kind of person
to know that you know Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
whenever whatever days
you're working put it in.
I have a designated place
that when I'm going here,
I'm focused, I'm shutting
off all those distractions
and I'm working.
And tip number seven is
do something you love.
And this is the tip
that comes up most often
when I look at famous entrepreneurs
and how they achieve success.
They did something that they love.
If you are forcing
yourself to do something
that you don't love you
can only do it for so long
before you're going to quit
and want to give up and want
to move on something else.
Because you don't love it.
Not every day is amazing
as an entrepreneur
but you have to actually
enjoy doing the work.
Where if you sit down
and you're doing the work
you don't see it as much
as being disciplined
to have to do it because
you actually enjoy doing it.
And so a lot of people
just set these big goals
for themselves and they'll
do whatever it takes
to go up and get there.
But if they don't actually
enjoy the process of doing it
they're never going to actually go out
and achieve those goals.
Much more important is that
the work that you're doing
is something that you
are passionate about.
There has to be something in your business
that you can get lost in.
There has to be.
If everything is just work to you
you're not going to make it.
Like quit now and go do something else
that you can get lost in.
Not every piece of your
business you're going
to be able to get lost in
especially at the beginning
because you're doing everything.
And you may not get lost in
the accounting of your business
maybe you love accounting
and that's great.
Be an accountant.
But otherwise a lot of
people don't want to do the
accounting side or don't want
to care about their taxes
and all that kind of stuff.
It has to get done.
But there has to be
something in your business
that you can get lost in
and forget what time it is.
And the more you're
doing that kind of work
the more you're going
to be able to not just
stay disciplined but
achieve your big goals.
And as soon as possible
I've been looking at
how can I build a team to
be able to take away some
of the things that I don't
like that I keep getting
drawn in by or keep procrastinating.
And give that to somebody
else so I can focus on
what I can be great at.
So those are my seven tips on
how to stay more disciplined.
I'd love to know what do you guys think.
What was your favorite tip?
What are you going to apply to your life
or your business immediately?
Did I miss an eight nine ten that you want
to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
And if you're commenting
in the first couple hours
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes
that we have going on.
If you want to vote on the
next top seven ways video
I should make check out the
link in the description.
You can go there give us your suggestions
and maybe you'll get lucky.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Maria Rodriguez
from Rishy Cup TV.
Thank you so much Rishy for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and posting
it on your Facebook.
I really really really appreciate it
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon